did you feel in a way with the Hanukkah
song that you are outing people who were
trying to be in the closet about their
Judaism like I had never thought about
the fact that David Lee Roth was Jewish
and of course when you say Dave go of
course yeah right the Lee throws you off
oh man I I guess I was doing it more not
outing anybody but I was more saying it
to the like look how cool we are
look look how great how many great ones
did you ever hear from someone and they
said you listen you're not yes but can
you [ __ ] take me out of your goddamn
Hanukkah song one guy was at this fist
at me I think in one of the versions 1
or 2 we say the owner of the Seattle
SuperSonics celebrates Hanukkah the
owner of the Seattle SuperSonics and I
did all when I did the song I would look
up info and stuff to make sure
everything was dosoo you sure exactly
and I guess I don't know his name but I
guess he bought the team after right and
so on it walked into a restaurant which
night and everyone said hey how you
doing blah blah blah all of a sudden I
hear come here come here
it was an older guy right he's with his
family I'm not family his wife and other
couples his age and I'm guessing in
their 60s they said hey how are ya and
the guy goes you're that guy does that a
song huh and I said yeah what song it
cuz the one with the Jew that Jewish all
right and I said oh yeah yeah and he
goes hey 86 that song and I go 86 what
do you mean and then he goes 86 that
song you say that I'm a Jew I'm not a
Jew mmm and then I go oh okay
and then Schneider goes hey well what's
the difference you don't want anyone
knowing you're you know saying you're a
Jew that's a bad thing or something like
that and the guy goes because I'm not a
man I got all Schneider and him got into
it I remember and I said I don't worry
about it buddy and I didn't want to get
into it with this guy in the sixties
about but what a weird thing we got was
about 86 that's